>> WELCOME BACK.
WE HAVE BRAND-NEW FOX NEWS VOTER
ANALYSIS THAT'S ON THE SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW, SHOWING
HOW VOTERS FEEL ABOUT A NUMBER
OF KEY ISSUES NOW, COULD ALL THE
FEAR MONGERING OVER DEMOCRACY
DYING TOMORROW BACKFIRE ON THE
DEMOCRATS?
FORMER OBAMA ADVISOR VAN JONES
IS RIPPING HIS OWN PARTY FOR
WASTING PRECIOUS TIME TRYING TO
STOKE VOTER FEARS INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON WHAT PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT.
>> I THINK THERE WAS THIS FOOL'S
GOLD, THE THREAT TO DEMOCRACY IS
SO SEVERE IN THE WAKE OF THIS
INSURRECTION, THE ELECTION
DENIERS, POSSIBLY GRABBING
CONTROL OF THE GOVERNMENT, THAT
WAS SOMETHING YOU HAD TO TALK
ABOUT, BUT YOU ALSO HAD TO TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
I THINK THE TRAGEDY HERE IS THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SOMETHING TO
SAY ON THE ECONOMY.
WE DIDN'T FOCUS ENOUGH FIREPOWER
ON THAT ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO
POTENTIALLY COST US.
>> AND ANOTHER DEM STRATEGIST IS
TEARING INTO JOE BIDEN FOR
ACCUSING VOTERS OF ALIGNING WITH
FASCISTS.
>> VOTERS HAVE TOLD US ALL YEAR
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT, AND I
THINK WE HAVE FOCUSED ON OTHER
THINGS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S CLOSING
MESSAGE LAST NIGHT ABOUT
DEMOCRACY IS ON THE BALLOT AGAIN
IS FRUSTRATING TO PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO, YOU KNOW, DON'T WANT TO SEE
HALF THE VOTERS IN AMERICA
ALIENATED OR SAYING -- BEING
ACCUSED OF ALIGNING WITH
FASCISTS, BECAUSE THEY'RE VOTING
FOR THEIR POCKETBOOK.
THAT'S NOT WHERE WE WANT TO BE.
>> BUT YOU GET WHAT YOU DESERVE.
DEMOCRATS, YOU SUCCEEDED IN
BOOSTING RIGHT WING CANDIDATES
IN 6 OF THE 13 REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES THAT YOU MEDDLED IN.
AS THE "NEW YORK POST" POINTS
OUT, MAGA REPUBLICANS WHO,
QUOTE, THREATEN DEMOCRACY MAY
HAVE DEMS TO THANK FOR THEIR
WINS ON TUESDAY.
NOT A VERY SMART MOVE, HUH,
HAROLD?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK AS WE GET
TOWARD THE AUTOPSY HERE OF THIS
RACE -- I'LL LET THE VOTES COME
IN --
>> OH, THIS IS A HOMICIDE NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED.
EVERY TWO OR FOUR YEARS THIS
HAPPENS.
IN 2018, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST
TERM, DEMOCRATS WON A MAJORITY.
IN 2020, DEMOCRATS WON.
TWO YEARS LATER, HERE WE ARE.
WHAT'S MOST REFRESHING ABOUT IT,
VOTERS ARE SPEAKING, SPEAKING
MORE QUICKLY.
BEFORE 1994, WHEN NEWT GINGRICH
WON THE HOUSE FOR REPUBLICANS IN
THE REVOLUTION, 40 YEARS
DEMOCRATS HAD BEEN IN CONTROL OF
THE HOUSE.
YOU THINK SINCE '94, IN 2006
DEMOCRATS FLIP IT.
2010 REPUBLICANS FLIPPED IT.
2018, DEMOCRATS FLIPPED IT
AGAIN.
MAYBE TONIGHT.
THAT'S FOUR TIMES IN LESS THAN
30 YEARS THAT WE'VE SEEN -- LESS
THAN 28 YEARS -- WE'VE SEEN THIS
HAPPEN.
I FIND IT REFRESHING.
AGAIN, I HOPE BOTH PARTIES TAKE
THE RIGHT LESSONS TONIGHT.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY WE'RE GOING
TO LOSE SO BADLY, BUT THE
MOMENTUM SEEMS TO HEAD THAT WAY,
BUT IF WE LOSE, I'LL SAY YOU
WERE RIGHT, AND LET'S FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
THAT'S WHAT VOTERS WANT
POLITICIANS TO DO.
>> VOTERS WANTED THE PROBLEMS TO
BE SOLVED BEFORE THE ELECTION,
WHICH IS WHY I THINK WE'LL SEE
WHAT WE SEE TONIGHT.
THE TRUTH IS, YOU KNOW, YOU HAD
AN ADMINISTRATION THAT WAS
TONE-DEAF TO WHAT AMERICANS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
WE'VE GOT DOUBLE-DIGIT INFLATION
IN A LOT OF PARTS OF THIS
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO BOTH
EAT AND DRIVE AND GET MEDICINE.
WHY WEREN'T THEY LISTENING?
>> CERTAIN THINGS THAT DEMOCRATS
WILL SAY, AND THE OTHER PARTY
WILL SAY, LISTEN, YOU GET HIT BY
HURRICANE IAN, DON'T BLAME ME
YOUR HOUSE GOT WRECKED, I HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
IT'S A NATURAL DISASTER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS, BUT I WAS STUNNED TO SEE
JOE BIDEN WHAT HE SAID ON
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY, I'M GOING
TO DESTROY THE COAL INDUSTRY,
STOPPING ALL DRILLING.
ALL OF A SUDDEN I'M FILLING UP
MY CAR, SEEING MY UTILITY BILL
DOUBLE, AND THE GUY THAT'S
RESPONSIBILITY, THAT DID NOTHING
BUT MAKE IT WORSE, JUST TOLD ME
HE'S BEEN LYING FOR THE LAST
THREE MONTHS, WHEN HE BLAMED THE
SAUDIS, VLADIMIR PUTIN, CEOs
OF OIL AND GAS COMPANIES.
YEAH, WE'RE COMING OUT OF A
PANDEMIC.
I UNDERSTAND IT.
CERTAIN HEAD WINDS, WE GET IT,
SUPPLY CHAIN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO MAKE IT WORSE,
YOU CAN MAKE IT BETTER.
I THINK, HAROLD, I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE
IT'S NOT YOUR AGENDA, I THINK HE
DID THINGS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
AGENDA, NOT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY HE CAN'T HIGH-FIVE
AND BRAG ABOUT IT.
>> HE DID FOR THE FAR LEFT, NOT
THE DEMOCRATIC AGENDA.
>> THAT'S WHY I SAY, IT'S NOT
REALLY YOUR AGENDA.
>> JESSE, WHY DO YOU THINK
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING DEMOCRACY
WILL DIE IF THEY'RE NOT IN
POWER?
AREN'T THEY THE ONES THAT DON'T
THINK AMERICA IS ALL THAT GREAT
TO BEGIN WITH?
>> IT IS TRUE.
JESSE JR. WOKE ME UP AT
5:00 A.M.
AND HE SAID, DAD, WHEN WE
DESTROY DEMOCRACY WHAT COMES
NEXT?
I SAID, JESSE JR., WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING?
>> IS THIS YOUR CHILDREN'S BOOK.
>> I SAID THINK ABOUT WHEN WE
SAID WE WOULD REPEAL AND REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
WE'RE GOING TO REPEAL IT AND
REPLACE WITH SOMETHING GREAT.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> YOU HAVEN'T REPEALED IT YET.
>> SMART KID.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
THE DEMOCRATS CAME UP WITH A
PHRASE, "ELECTION DENIER," THAT
PEOPLE ONLY SAY IT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, ON CNN, IN THE BELTWAY.
95% OF THE COUNTRY DOES NOT KNOW
WHAT THE PHRASE ELECTION DENIER
MEANS.
THEY'RE RUNNING AN ELECTION
BASED ON NOT THE FUTURE, NOT THE
PRESENCE, BUT THE PAST, BECAUSE
A COUPLE REPUBLICANS SAY THERE
WERE A SHENANIGANS A FEW YEARS
AGO, A COUPLE REPUBLICANS HAVE A
GRUDGE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TWO
YEARS, A COUPLE REPUBLICANS FELT
ROBBED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TWO
YEARS AGO, BUT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING ROBBED NOW, AND THEY'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT ACTUAL
ROBBERIES, PEOPLE LOSING THEIR
MONEY AND LIVES.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
REPUBLICANS WHO FELT ROBBED TWO
YEARS AGO.
>> DANA, SPEAKING OF ELECTION
DENIERS, I MEAN STACEY ABRAMS,
SHE NOW IS ALREADY BUILDING UP A
DEFENSE FOR HER NEXT ARGUMENT,
JUSTIFICATION THAT APPARENTLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN ARE BEING
FED MISINFORMATION, WHICH WILL
THEN JUSTIFY HER SAYING, YOU
KNOW, OH, WE HAVE THAT SOUND?
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE KNOW THAT BLACK VOTERS ARE
OFTEN DISCOUNTED, AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS YEAR BLACK
MEN HAVE BEEN A VERY TARGETED
POPULATION FOR MISINFORMATION.
NOT MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
THEY WANT, BUT ABOUT WHY THEY
WANT WHAT THEY DESERVE.
MY CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN THE ONLY
ONE THAT'S VERY INTENTIONALLY,
THOUGHTFULLY AND CONSISTENTLY
REACHED OUT.
>> OKAY.
SO IN ADDITION TO HER DEFENDING
HER NEXT ARGUMENT THAT SHE LOST
BECAUSE OF X,Y OR Z, ISN'T SHE
KIND OF TRASHING AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN AS BEING INCAPABLE
OF DIFFERENTIATING BETWEEN THE
BETWEEN THETRUTH AND MISTRUTHS?
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY KNEW
THEY NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING TO
REACH OUT TO MINORITY VOTERS.
YOU LOOK AT THE HOUSE
RECRUITMENTS IN PARTICULAR, THAT
RAINBOW IS ALL THERE.
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE WAS A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO
THEM.
THE OTHER THING IS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID BETTER WITH BLACK MEN.
HE DIDN'T WIN THEM ALL
OBVIOUSLY.
HE STARTED TO DO BETTER.
WHY?
LOOK, ALL OF THEM HAVE TO DRIVE
TO WORK.
RIGHT?
MAYBE THEY'RE PAYING DIESEL
PRICES.
ALL OF THEM ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
THEY GET THAT.
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS BASED
ON THEIR OWN POCKETBOOK ISSUES
AND LIVELIHOOD.
SHE HAD PROBLEMS -- THIS IS
GOING BACK THREE MONTHS AGO, SO
SHE KNEW THAT WAS COMING.
I DON'T EVEN WHY THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T LISTEN TO VAN JONES.
EVERY SINGLE ELECTION HE CALLS
IT.
NOBODY LISTENS TO HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
ON THE FOX NEWS VOTER ANALYSIS
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF YOUR
SCREEN, SOME QUESTIONS ARE
INTERESTING, ABOUT THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT, HOW IT SHOULD DO
MORE OR LESS, BUT THE NUMBERS
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN, THEY'RE
REALLY BAD.
>> IF DEMOCRATS HAD SAID, NO
CASHLESS BAIL, FIRE WEAK
PROSECUTORS, PUT PEOPLE ON THE
BORDER TO SECURE IT, THIS
APPEALS TO EVERYBODY.
YOU COULD HAVE TOLD JESSE JR.
AND WE'D BE HAVING A DIFFE